there is a rule which is that there is
supposed to be extra consideration given
to military veterans in immigration
cases meaning that if you have a
military veteran who does not have legal
status or maybe was here on a visa that
has expired and they have not been able
to get citizenship as a result of being
in the military yet that special
consideration is given to them when you
process them through the immigration a
sort of court system and adjudication
system and unfortunately the Donald
Trump administration is not following
that rule more and more non-citizens are
being deported who are veterans of the
American military how many we don't
actually know because record-keeping has
been so atrocious the Government
Accountability Office found that 250
veterans are subject to removal 92 have
been deported we've deported nearly a
hundred military veterans the issue here
is not legality issue here is that
officials are going against their own
guidelines about how this is supposed to
be handled there are two memos since
2004 addressing exactly this issue
there's a memo from 2015 which says that
anytime you are looking at deporting a
military veteran it must be set for a
higher review if you are going to deport
a military veteran you need a special
document explaining why is it that you
are deporting this military veteran this
is not being done okay and there's this
meme that we've dealt with many times
before which is that the right supports
the troops and the left doesn't and of
course this could not be further from
the truth
I've said before yeah I'm on the left
and I support the troops I don't want to
send them to military conflicts as
political pawns where they may be
injured or killed or traumatized for
life that's how I support the troops by
really making military action the
absolute last resort and using it so
sparingly only when we really are in
immediate danger not fighting political
wars the way Republicans have been doing
for decades at this point in time health
care I support the troops by making sure
that or wanting at least I can't make
sure
personally and the system is not working
well but demanding and asking for
veterans to really get good medical care
and it's got to happen with immigration
as well and it is not happening here the
Republicans love veterans as props props
on stages props on aircraft carriers
when they declare mission accomplished
dead veterans that they can honor and
use for political gain but when it comes
to just treating them like real people
recognizing their sacrifice when we
consider their immigration status when
we consider the health care that we
provide to them when we consider job
opportunities that we are furnishing
that is where all of a sudden the right
does not care I wish the support the
troops Brigade on the right simply
supported them for real and it's
disgusting that this is going on and
this is an example of why we can't allow
Trump to use Twitter to set the
narrative and to distract from really
serious things that are going on